hello welcome to lobby against bots
weekly hung out every Tuesday at two
p.m. pacific right here on gamespot com
I'm your host Daniel Dwyer join as ever
by mr. Christopher waters oh yeah Jeff
Chrisman's here as well hi hey they low
but do well and did you hear the world
of action sports is returning uh I mean
I'd never left as far as I'm visitor I
live in the world of action sports in
that I guess Cairo and Razor scooter
here like riding on a rail the whole
time and then threw that thing aside no
you didn't you right around the office
all the time well yeah I mean they have
to get to these meetings somehow brother
ever seen a man Ollie in a desk chair
yeah I know yeah sky right here at tony
hawk pro skater five kind of at a leak
this morning but it's since been
confirmed by game informer yeah yeah
even their their new issue they they
confirm it as Tony Hawk's Pro Skater
five that's the name yeah is the fifth
tony hawk pro skater right yeah thats
chef that leaked out the oh yeah from
the thing that just said Tony Hawk 5 on
it kind of off to the side yeah yeah
they've catering guy info is on point
yeah exactly i think that guy's a
celebrity chef or something is now far
as I think I feel like that's going to
be that like getting in with catering
companies is the new listening in on
stock unlike investors goals Nan's are
like slipping into these meetings yeah
figuring stuff out yeah we grabbing your
ass off we're gonna talk about earnings
calls later on the show because EA just
put out some stuff earlier but 15
minutes ago but yeah tony hawk pro
skater 5 i returned to the series Robo
mode or doing it who made they have a
sort of mmm Scottish oo history with the
series they were responsible for the
weirds I made ride yeah they made shred
yeah and then they made tony hawk's pro
skater HD which you would think would be
like i am of the thing ended up being
quite a bummer yeah any of those games
you mentioned good to know no not yeah
you know I think we're I think there's a
difference though like yeah like ridin
shred are only are like they're like
yeah they're trying to well they're
trying to be a different thing and I
remember the first time I got on the
tony hawk ride board at e3 it actually
worked surprisingly well and I was like
okay I guess I can see what you're going
for like obviously takes some of the
steering out of it you're kind of doing
a different thing but as soon as I got
one
in our office it was a mess it didn't it
just didn't work and and amount of
somalia there's on the guinness jumping
up and down on the amount of free space
it required around the board to handle
the sensors and stuff well really was
really okay kind of extreme i was
required that much peripheral stuff he
kind of you know with a connect or
something like a move you imagine you
need the big space to move but like this
looks like you could legitimately do it
on a carpet square that big also it has
sensors on the side of it see what he
did there like i gotta kind of waving in
front of the center's to say i'm
grabbing the board right uh so if you
have items in that radius and you're
moving the board around it sometimes
detects those items as you grabbing the
board rest breaks everything so uh yeah
it was i I'll all whoa artifacting like
Ivan razy that is not tony hawk times I
they had an idea and I applaud them for
having the idea but boy that thing
produced a couple of really bad games
yeah sure it was like a snow board game
or something apparently I actually
hadn't realized Anthony just said yeah
before we started but then toys for Bob
the tony hawk's downhill jam yeah you
launch game so I you know Tony Hawk
remember that at the time at which ride
came out Tony Hawk was kind of done so
we'd gone one two three four on the
ground on the ground to project a
project eight was the eighth game okay
so or so seven was American wasteland
than project eight then what was the
last one calls yep yep there was another
one because I think they got up to nine
and then nine he'll Jam no no I want to
say there was a hadn't have somebody go
he's gone there's internet will go guys
want me to just put in the comments lap
this up no yeah right now while you're
did I find out okay yes yeah so it had
been like well trodden grand by the time
totally like project eight like that's
the nail the trick slow-mo stuff they
were doing at that point was just kind
of them bolting on systems that didn't
need to be there so like that thing had
gotten way far away from what it
originally was by the time bride who
came along you were just laying sure of
course why not so what do you expect of
this one it seems from
what little information we have that
they are returning to the sort of two
three era of having a core bunch of
skaters I like a kind of like that
they're not going back into like or
we're gonna pull back like cream
Campbell and like yeah like they need to
update the roster summit and hd's in
Denver she was a Soviet right brow thank
you yes moving around classic not bad no
a project eight not like not bad games
but just you know that that series was
so well worn at that point that you know
that they were just on their on their
downward slope but yeah like the the
roster stuff got I think even in that
point got a little strange yeah they I
mean HD had new skaters in it that some
of which are actually appearing in Tony
on phone in some point on there you said
it is your five yeah somewhat along are
you had skate come into the picture and
that was like that was fresh it felt
distinct and different and just had
great was the responsiveness sort of the
naturalistic approach as it most of the
more over-the-top Tony Hawk stuff yeah I
mean you know Tony Hawk was a game where
you were doing special grinds where
dudes were pulling out guitars and
burning flags you know what about it
came to the point where I guess yeah
well I can't came to the point as well
where if you're playing I can properly
like two or three you were spending the
two minute run on a single really like
you were once they put into the vert
sortable zat the reverb I was having a
sony are free yeah I was just two
minutes of one long combo yes awesome it
was awesome so skate was like a really
good alternate approach to that where it
kind of got back to slightly more
realistic skating where you know yeah
your trick lines were a little more like
what something that seems a little more
feasible yeah with you know goals that
were kind of appropriate and i liked the
attitude of skate like you know their
their full motion video intros that were
like a skate video not to life you know
just like a real crazy stuff there it
seemed way more in touch with in the way
that Tony Hawk one and two kind of did
it felt way more in touch with skate
culture at that point totally as well
yeah and also I think gaming culture
like it sort of felt like this sort of
opened more open area they're like yeah
like we're going to have fun with some
ragdoll physics yeah that just sort of
felt like a fresh take on the situation
you know there were a lot goals
involving you just like getting cool
photos for Thrasher
oh yeah yeah the stuff was like
relatively modest compared to this light
you need to grind this and then cause an
earthquake and that everything could
blow up and which that's fine i think
there was there was always room for both
you know i think both approaches were so
different at that point that that that i
enjoyed both of them in their own way
let's get into some details on what we
do know about this one of them
apparently coming out to ps4 and xbox
one with ps3 360 versions coming later
in the year and love power-ups and the
ability to shoot projectiles for a
specific mission they've done before
yeah yeah before before you get in for
an important book I got people have been
looking at my this games garbage like
keep mind a lot of the tony hawk games
are well garbage is a strong word but
you know when they when they fell off
they fell off yeah they had a
multiplayer mode that was just
deathmatch it was like um dude kickflip
star ball right I one of the board of
the back of the board is when kick flips
for forward fireballs heelflip career no
shove it's for when I decide yeah
totally so like they've done that
they've had objectives where you're
throwing tomatoes at people and like
that sort of stuff has existed before to
highlight it as part of your announce it
may be the wrong way to go but that's
that's more of a marketing rollout issue
than something with the game I think
it's going to have co-op and competitive
play a seamless online and you can
create your own skate parks which again
is nothing was it thug was the first one
baby do that oh I'm added it for but
yeah like that'll come like past four
they all kind of run together in terms
of features like yeah we're added like
the spine transfer stuff that you know
the game already kind of had but it kind
of codified that a little more
succinctly i guess and but you know
after three the mechanics started
mattering less and less to me like once
you get off the board is like one yeah
don't don't do that in terms of the
lineup then like we said like nyjah
huston's in it who like I remember being
like the 67 year old kid who was able to
do kick flips right now he's like 20
he's like a grown-up the actual pro
skateboarder same deal like Riley Hawk
is in it yep Riley Hawk Lizzie Armand so
Chris Cole david gonzales Chris Cole was
in one skate and andrew reynolds as well
as Reynolds was in the early Tony okay
yeah so it's not like we've got a we've
got a completely new roster was it ever
was it ever the roster that appealed to
you like
you ever like sweet bam margera san juan
and non-interest only knows i think like
the i think it worked the other way
around was like the reason i'm sitting
here wearing a vance church is because
growing up in ireland i played tony
hawk's too and was like skateboarding's
[ __ ] cool and then i bought a
skateboard and I skateboarder for like
six years and I played every one of
those games so like I gotta know if
they're trying to like reconnect with
that like that was a very time in place
type yeah skateboarding was huge you
think about I mean you know I don't
really keep up with it the same way that
I used to but you think about kind of
what skateboarding became in the wake of
that and the rise of the x-games again
all that sort of stuff that like very
hyper competitive stuff that like you
know the skate would get into here and
there but not you know at the expense of
like Street skating that to me is what's
interesting about skateboarding like you
know that kind of makeshift like you
know we're making things happen on the
street or we're building our own half by
be doing this but you know I bet I don't
find that a finding spa yeah but much
like eSports is like a terrible
representation of like actual
competitive gaming in a spiritual way
and super solace in a lot of form of its
forms like like professional
skateboarding looked like it went that
way to yeah now it's on espn2 and you're
just like well I'm sit here and watch
these guys like it's super impressive
but I just want to watch Yeah right over
and over again you know go watch the
search for animal chin again yeah you
know and so if you're making a Tony Hawk
skating game now it's that it's got to
be that kind of skating right because
you're pulling the Tony Hawk name I mean
he's he's the the name yeah there's like
a mini game like glitzy legally
rejecting your knees with the serum so
you can keep going in the fruit pie
right yeah I oh I think you know if you
look at some of the screenshots that
game a former poster with their story
like you know they're showing warehouses
with you know whales and ramps and you
know from fun boxes and that sort of
stuff when it seems kind of grounded in
that stuff I don't think it's gonna be
like massive vert ramps for huge you
know whatever stuff but you know who
knows how many different levels they'll
have or what though what their approach
will be yeah like you think about that
game like originally it was two minute
runs yeah and then the levels were built
to for you to get to where you need to
get to within two minutes and then by
four they kind of gotten bigger and
and started blowing it out sounds like I
hope they don't think like to make a
classic tony hawk game they have to go
back to that because i think that the
run timer is fine for like a classic
mode but i think that they they were
right to get away from them from it when
they did and embrace kind of larger
levels in a bigger world and you know
add timers where you need to okay you
have 15 seconds to do this like that's
what they eventually kind of settle on
for like the thug games yes I think that
worked pretty well cool well I guess
we'll get more information over the
coming year and will hopefully be this
will be robo botos sort of breakthrough
tony hawk game there's definitely talent
at robo moto like you know i remember
talking to them when HD was coming out
and there were people there who
understood precisely what they were
working on but HD just didn't come
together you know I I hope they can put
it together for this like if they don't
then this has to be it for ya the
franchise right because the you know
this is this is kind of the
make-or-break moment yes reboot number
four so yeah yeah cool time will tell
Jeff thanks very much for coming on yeah
I'm sorry miss Patterson if you have any
thoughts on the future of tony hawk or
what your favorite game was by all means
please leave it in the comments below